[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien sur public c'est
là en étant ensemble du lundi au jeudi à
18h et 22h pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts et voici
le sommaire de ce 26 juin à quel point
Vladimir Poutine est-il fragilisé par le
putsch avorté de la milice Wagner où est
passé son chef et vieilli Prigogine et
que risque-t-il l'Ukraine peut-elle
profiter des fissures apparues au sein
du pouvoir russe ces questions ne
trouveront pas toutes de réponses
rapides mais elle démontre que la folle
journée de samedi a ouvert une nouvelle
ère dans la guerre en Ukraine on amorce
des pistes de réflexion on se projette
vers les prochaines semaines juste après
ces titres et puis on reste au cœur des
enjeux de défense dans notre second
débat avec la loi de programmation
militaire examen qui débute ce mardi au
Sénat 413 milliards d'euros investis
d'ici 2030 budget historique rappelle le
président de la République
c'est un appel à réinvestir massivement
dans notre défense
si nous Européens voulons la paix nous
devons nous en donner les moyens
la France prend sa part ce budget en
forte hausse est-il en trompe l'oeil
est-ce un saupoudrage inadapté à un
conflit de haute intensité de type
ukrainien l'industrie de défense
française est-elle en capacité de
produire plus d'armes réponse dans 45
minutes mais d'abord les dernières infos
en provenance de Russie ou comment
donner l'impression d'un lundi presque
comme les autres Jonathan du priez
semblant de retour à la normale en
Russie après la rébellion avortée de
Wagner les habitants de Rostov vivent
d'un million d'habitants ont contrôlé
quelques heures par les paramilitaires
semble soulager du départ des
mercenaires
je suis soulagée car lorsque la routine
de la ville change et que vous ne
comprenez pas ce qui se passe vous vous
sentez très anxieux et en danger oui
personnellement je pense qu'il vaut
mieux régler les choses sur le champ de
bataille et ne pas venir dans les villes
ici Rostov c'est calme et paisible donc
ça ne sert à rien de régler les choses
avec des chars d'assaut si la tension
est retombée d'un cran Wagner a réalisé
une démonstration de force et fortement
remis en cause l'autorité de Vladimir
Poutine le maître du Kremlin est
d'ailleurs apparu dans une vidéo
aujourd'hui la première fois depuis les
événements du week-end le président
russe ne fait aucune mention du groupe
Wagner mais évoque des défis pour
l'industrie face aux sanctions
occidentales
ce sont ces gens là à la fois des jeunes
et des spécialistes expérimentés les
équipes de nos entreprises qui ont
assuré le fonctionnement stable de
l'industrie russe son développement face
à de sévères des physiques extérieures
le coût de pression deviennes Prigogine
sur le Kremlin laisse toutefois de
nombreuses questions en suspens on
ignore pour le moment pourquoi l'homme a
fait volte-face alors qu'il prétendait
être à 200 km de Moscou se pose aussi la
question du devenir de Wagner l'armée
russe pourrait être tentée d'intégrer
les mercenaires à marche forcées cet
épisode pourrait aussi bouleverser le
cours de la guerre sorti de son silence
et gaini Prigogine affirme en tout cas
n'avoir pas voulu renverser Vladimir
Poutine nous n'avions pas pour objectif
de renverser le régiment place et le
gouvernement légitime le but de la
marche était de ne pas permettre la
destruction du groupe Wagner de leur
côté les chancelleries occidentales
préfèrent ne pas trop spéculer vous
savez la prudence que nous avons mise à
ne pas commenter
au-delà de ce qui paraissait être
utile rappeler en termes de contact avec
nos partenaires en termes de suivi de la
situation rappeler qu'il s'agit de faire
intérieur russe de son côté Moscou
affiche une certaine sérénité et jure
que la mutinerie menée par Wagner
n'affectera en aucun cas l'intervention
militaire russe en Ukraine je vous
présente tout de suite mes invités
vous êtes politologue spécialiste du
monde slave auteur de Goodbye Poutine du
KGB au crime de guerre livre publié chez
ginkoédition Patricia lemonniere bonsoir
Patricia bienvenue vous êtes grand
reportir spécialisé relation
internationales j'accueille également
Christian macarian bonsoir et bienvenue
éditorialiste international au point et
radioclassique et Mathieu croissanto
bonsoir Mathieu éditorialiste politique
on va peut-être commencer par se mettre
d'accord sur le sur les mots comment
vous qualifiez ce qui s'est passé samedi
elle aime blanc coup d'État punch
noninerie et et beaucoup de théâtre dans
tout ça de dramatisation de spectacle de
je veux dire honnêtement c'était
difficile de prendre ça au sérieux quand
on connaît un petit peu le dessous des
choses et puis sa fameuse marche pour la
justice contre la corruption etc qui
s'arrête brutalement à 200 km de Moscou
on se demande pourquoi il s'arrête je
veux dire d'autant plus qu'il n'a
rencontré aucun obstacle sur la route on
l'a laissé partir tant à lui il était
toujours à Rostov d'ailleurs en train de
discuter prendre le thé avec les gens
qui étaient là-bas alors qu'ils auraient
pu l'arrêter lui par exemple puisque
c'était le quartier général il y avait
des militaires et le fameux guerassimov
apparemment n'y était pas alors qu'il
aurait dû y être enfin bref et puis non
moi tout ça si vous voulez bon c'est
compliqué parce que vous disiez c'est du
théâtre
j'y croyais pas vraiment je peux pas
expliquer pourquoi parce que vous savez
on a eu quand même d'autres poutres en
91 en 93 et c'était pas du tout pareil
et d'ailleurs même celui de 91 au début
se fait avoir et puis après on a compris
que Gorby était complice quand une fois
absolument mais au début tout le monde
disait c'est un pauvre gorbit il y a un
contre Gorby etc par contre le vrai
de 93 ça c'était vraiment de oui de
93 c'était vraiment un coup de contre
elle signe et là il y a eu des morts
parce qu'il a fait tirer sur le
Parlement mais là je ne sais pas où
c'était outré ou c'était je peux pas
expliquer je me suis dit mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette mascarade plutôt du
passé
de reparler évidemment dans ce débat de
de privilégie de Patricia elmonier on va
revoir on l'a vu rapidement dans dans le
sujet d'ouverture donc il y a eu un
message audio en fait du chef de la
Méduse Wagner cet après-midi dans lequel
il dit notamment nous n'avions pas pour
objectif de renverser le régiment place
et le gouvernement légitime le but de la
marche c'était de ne pas permettre la
destruction du groupe Wagner donc alors
est-ce qu'on est obligé de croire
Prigogine je ne sais pas il dit aussi
dans ce message l'avancée de Wagner vers
Moscou a révélé de graves problèmes de
sécurité en Russie donc le prix gaugine
d'avant il est il est il est jamais très
loin quoi il continue de taper sur le
système de défense russe mais avec 48
heures de recul comment vous analysez ce
qui s'est passé moi c'est le cuisson
un coup de colère j'ai envie de dire
d'un homme qui est connu pour être un
impulsif
et qui donc vu les menaces qui planaient
sur lui depuis un certain temps avec le
fait que les milices toutes les milices
parce qu'il n'y a pas que la sienne il
faut pas l'oublier caddy Rove d'ailleurs
avait déjà signé toutes les milices
devaient rentrer dans l'armée c'est à
dire ces deux j'ai envie de dire ces
deux verticales du pouvoir qui existait
à l'armée officielle et les armées
privées en quelque sorte devait se
réunir en un seul corps et là il a pas
supporté d'ailleurs il le dit dans son
message aujourd'hui on s'est réuni avec
mes hommes en fait le Conseil grosso
modo d'administration de la Wagner
milice se sont réunis et ont décidé que
c'était vraiment pas possible de d'être
réintégré donc pour la défense de mes
hommes pour la défense de notre honneur
j'ai voulu en gros faire cette marche
enfin je m'attendais même pas à pouvoir
y aller comme ça dit-il un peu et bien
j'ai fait cette marche pour en gros
alerter le pouvoir pour alerter Vladimir
mon ami en quelque sorte ça c'est son
discours mais je crois que vraiment il y
a aussi vraiment le coup de sang d'un
homme très impulsif très en commun qui
était au point de tout
perdre parce que si ça milice fondait
dans l'armée oui d'après de l'Afrique de
son usine à troll n’y avait-il pas là à
une volonté de remettre un peu d'ordre
dans la maison Christian macarian alors
si c'est pas un coup d'état c'est quoi
pour vous c'est un raid décidé par un
homme qui est menacé comme Patricia
vient de l'expliquer à la date du
premier juillet ça ministre devait et
elle va disparaître les cadres donc
c'est du business vont être fondus dans
l'armée et les soldats un par un vont
devoir signer des contre-individuelles
de rattachement à l'armée régulière donc
ils vont passer les fameux criminels
sous l'armée régulière avant ça il y a
eu un autre coup dur donc Prigogine à
mon avis à mijoter son cou il y a eu une
autre coup dur pour Prigogine c'est que
l'armée s'est arrosée le privilège de
vider les prisons et d'aller recruter en
tôle ce qui était un peu monopole
d'évolue jusque là un Prigogine brigo
Gina donc beaucoup perdu et il a vu en
deux mois que le pouvoir voulait le
mettre au pas et donc il a à mon avis
préparé son coup une sorte de baroud
d'honneur dont il espérait sûrement une
meilleure négociation quant à ses
avantages et ces derniers privilèges
pour justement ne pas être effacé
complètement maisons-nous à la place de
prégogène s'il n'avait rien fait sa
liquidation ce serait faite sans un pli
là il a quelque part sûrement négocier
des choses un peu plus secrètes puisque
nous nous connaissons pas
mes titres de la question qui resteront
sans réponse
supposément négocié une côte dépêcher
ardemment par le Kremlin c'est évident
plusieurs fois
reste le suivant voici un homme fort
Vladimir Poutine très fort très serein
qui garantit toute la sécurité la
puissance de son pays assailli par
l'Occident dévastateur et décadent voici
donc un homme qui le matin parle je le
cite de châtiment inévitable et qu'il
l'après-midi passe un accord un
arrangement avec le factieux alors on y
reviendra là dessus on y reviendra
évidemment sur la fragilisation de de
Vladimir Poutine mais quand même je
reviens à une blonde sur eux ces images
qui nous ont tous sidérées de de des
troupes de Wagner qui qui faisait route
vers vers Moscou est-ce que ça suppose à
minima des défaillances ou à Maximin des
complicités
même s'il a eu un coup de sens qui est
fort possible parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un sanguin a dû quand même
s'assurer quelques soutiens avant de
lancer son opération tel que je connais
le bonhomme bon et le problème c'est que
les soutiens en question peut-être
existaient-ils au départ puis petit à
petit il semblerait que les gens qui la
contacter et qui étaient prêts à le
soutenir et fait marcher une arrière et
dans ce cas là il s'est retrouvé seul et
finalement
je pense que dans la coulisse les
services secrets ont dû le menacer en
fin ils savent très bien faire ça la
terreur psychologique on va s'occuper de
tes enfants on va s'occuper de ta mère
etc etc il a dû se dire bon ils vont
peut-être mieux que j'arrête parce que
sinon ça va se gâter mais le problème
c'est que il a il avait des cartes en
main parce que si quelqu'un qui a
participé à nombre d'opérations
financières de Vladimir Poutine il a
aidé à placer de l'argent dans les
paradis fiscaux etc il connaît beaucoup
de secrets de Vladimir Poutine et donc
il pouvait menacer de révéler des choses
enfin je veux dire est-ce que c'est une
vraie négociation à mon avis c'est son
assurance vie mes connaissant Poutine
puisque il a trahi il risque de le payer
cher et chez Poutine quand on trahi
sentence c'est la mort on va détailler
dans un instant le ce qu'est le business
de la milice Wagner er du groupe Wagner
et prigogne mais un mot Patricia
lemonnière sur ces supposés complicités
au sein soit de l'armée russe soit de
l'administration russe il y a quelques
personnes je ne sais pas combien qui ont
pris des risques et qui vont peut-être
le payer alors on et c'est là que tous
ces jouets quand un de ses amis j'ai
envie de dire dans le camp militaire qui
servait pratiquement d'interface entre
lui et gueram simov c'est le général
soroviking qui était ce qu'on a appelé
le boucher de Damas ou d'Alep ou de ce
que vous voulez en français qui s'était
qui avait montré ses talents en Syrie
pour l'armée russe et bien quand
celui-ci immédiatement pratiquement a
dit ouh là là on a mis Prigogine il faut
arrêter c'est pas sérieux cette avancée
c'est calme-toi et tout de suite lui qui
devait en théorique qui est le plus
proche au sein qui était le plus proche
au sein de l'armée de Prigogine avec
d'autres moins gradés et bien tout de
suite lui il a fait des flexiogestion
entièrement d'accord avec vous les
services de renseignement
c'est qui se dit mais j'entends souvent
Patricia la question se posait c'est
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une purge
dans les jours où les semaines qui
viennent au sein de l'armée ou de la ou
de l'administration aussi il y a eu des
complicités
que va-t-on faire de ces deux militaires
qui discutaient même s'ils avaient l'air
un peu coincé quand même ils n'ont pas
arrêté privé alors qu'ils avaient quand
même à rester sur le don les moyens de
l'arrêter que va-t-il se passer pour
tous ces gens là qui compte à cadirof
qui devait foncer pour faire des choses
empêcher
l'armée de Prigogine les 4000 hommes de
montée il est resté il est pas arrivé
rapidement non plus qu'à des robes donc
embouteillages c'est terrible et sur les
routes et donc que va être vous savez
bon effectivement Vladimir Poutine on
l'a tous dit autant cette table il a la
dent dure pour ceux qui ne trahissent et
donc et bien il peut y avoir mais avec
un temps différent
la vraie question c'est moi ce qui me
fascine le plus cette pérennité de
shinigou alors Shibu c'est le Ministre
toujours en interne même par les gens du
renseignement il y a des gens du
renseignement le numéro 2 du
renseignement a dit à prix gaugine qui
est en train de se retirer ou si tu
pouvais emmener grosso modo chez igo et
guerracmoa avec toi ça veut dire que
dans le renseignement il y a quand même
des gens qui sont très critiques
vis-à-vis de chez on reste concentrer
encore un instant sur sur la
personnalité et le business des prix
d'origine grâce à Steve Jourdain qui va
nous rejoindre tout de suite sur ce
plateau bonsoir Steve bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous on parle de lui comme
d'un entrepreneur de guerre un business
qui fonctionne bien oui un business de
la mort très juteux la devanture de la
boutique c'est le groupe paramilitaire
Wagner créé en mai 2014 à la faveur de
l'annexion de la Crimée et dès 2015
après ses premiers faits d'armes sur la
péninsule evegaini prilogie remporte de
gros avec le ministère de la Défense
russe on parle au total d'une enveloppe
d'un milliard d'euros en échange du
ravitaillement vivre de l'armée
l'appétit de l'homme d'affaires s'étend
aussi jusqu'à la Syrie ou à partir de
septembre 2015 Poutine décide
d'intervenir trigogine et ses milices
sont sur le terrain pour aider Bachar
al-Assad contre l'État islamique il
obtient en échange que 25% des revenus
des champs pétroliers et gaziers
récupérés aux mains des djihadistes lui
reviennent directement ça correspond à
plusieurs dizaines dizaines voire
centaines de millions d'euros et en
Afrique Thomas même deal coup de main
militaire coup de main sécuritaire
contre prédation des ressources locales
sur le continent Wagner au père depuis
2018 il est notamment présent au Soudan
en République centrafricaine en haut
Libye et au Mali dans ces pays il s'est
progressivement implanté dans le secteur
minier et pétrolier alors méprigognes
dans ce groupe Wagner c'est pas que du
business non c'est aussi un maître de la
propagande c'est lui qui est à l'origine
des campagnes de désinformation à grande
échelle lancée par le Kremlin il possède
ce qu'on une usine à troll il s'agit de
gens qui sont payés pour diffuser sur
internet ou sur les réseaux sociaux des
informations partielles voire
mensongères cela vise notamment des
opposants avec Vladimir Poutine au total
on estime que cette usine à troll de
trigogine compte environ 400 personnes
sont gros cons Thomas date de la
présidentielle américaine de 2016 à
cette occasion il avait vraiment en
faveur de la propagande électorale de
Donald Trump et vous nous décrivez en
quelque sorte un voyou d'ailleurs ça a
commencé comme ça dans sa jeunesse oui
tout a commencé par un vol crapuleux
dans une rue sombre de Saint-Pétersbourg
une femme circule seule avec son sac à
main on est en mars 1980 Prigogine et
ses amis s'en prennent à elle résultat
12 ans de prison quand brigogine
retrouve la liberté l'Union soviétique
n'existe plus tous les moyens sont à
leur bons pour gagner sa vie il devient
vendeur de hot-dog avant de se lancer
dans la restauration de luxe à cette
occasion il rencontre un certain
Vladimir Poutine qui fait alors partie
de l'élite locale c'est lui qui va lui
permettre d'amasser son premier mill lui
confiant le monopole sur la restauration
des écoles de Moscou puis de l'armée
russe on comprend mieux Thomas pourquoi
aujourd'hui Poutine se sent trahi par
celui qui lui doit à peu près tout merci
beaucoup Steve Jourdain il y a une
aspect un peu de mafieux dans cette
histoire aussi donc il faut pas
complètement
le système Poutine est fondé sur comme
les matriochka qui s'emboîtent l'une
dans l'autre sur un certain nombre de
mafia qui qui s'emboîtent et qui font
que un homme comme Pierre Prigogine qui
se trouve au centre de cet emboîtement
est très difficile à déloger à déraciner
et à isoler il faut qu'il ait quand même
beaucoup d'informations et de contact
avec d'autres types d'organisations
comparables à la sienne pour arriver à
faire quelque chose qui moi me stupéfi
encore 48 heures après ce raid
c'est-à-dire la prise de Rostov sur le
don la base militaire d'où toute la
guerre de la Russie contre l'Ukraine est
commandée enfin je sais pas si on se
rend compte de ce oui c'était pas
n'importe quel cible mais c'est énorme
et il entre là-dedans
sans trop de casse même très peu c'est
après qu'il va y avoir de la casse sur
la route vers le nord et qui vont
d'ailleurs faire un petit carnage parce
que on l'oublie j'en tirer sur des
hélicoptères et les ont abattu et ils
ont fait des victimes des victimes de
l'armée régulière russe donc
ça va être très difficile à pardonner
pour Vladimir Poutine même s'il prendra
son temps pour le faire mais je reviens
à ce que vous disiez oui c'est un
système mafieux parce que Vladimir
Poutine l'a fondé ainsi vous avez une
colonne l'État comme il y avait à
l'époque soviétique l'État et le parti
l'État ne comptait pas la Constitution
ne comptait pas c'est le parti et le
Bureau politique qui décidait de tout là
il n'y a plus de partie il y a le parti
du président Russ c'est-à-dire là encore
une mafia et il a d'une certaine manière
entourée tous les corps puissants de
l'État comme l'armée de de corps mafieux
par exemple pourquoi faire surgir
Wagner dans les flancs de l'armée parce
que Wagner permet ce que l'armée ne peut
pas faire de subvertir certains États
étrangers en Afrique et au Moyen-Orient
et aujourd'hui privogine spécialiste de
la subversion exerce ses talents de
subversion à l'intérieur de la Russie il
y a une sorte de logique mais que
Prigogine soit au contact de différentes
autres matières mafia ça fait absolument
pas l'ombre d'un doute sans quoi il
n'aurait pas pu prévoir ce raid là qui
de mon point de vue a été quand même
organisé
est-ce que c'est pris d'origine n'a pas
été châtié une certaine manière ou voilà
c'est le terme de Poutine est-ce que
c'est parce qu'en fait la Russie ne peut
pas s'en
le châtiment peut être différent alors
d'abord le châtiment regardez la faire
scripal le type alors il faut rappeler
ce que c'est alors
empoisonné dans un jardin public en
Angleterre à côté de sa fille qui n'y
est pour rien et qui va malheureusement
être empoisonné en même temps il ne
meurt pas mais qu'est-ce qui lui
reprochait d'avoir été d'avoir d'être
passé à l'ouest et d'avoir ensuite fait
volte-face c'est à dire qu'il a fait une
sorte d'aller retour à partir des
services et qu'ensuite
tout ça avait été oublié pour avoir
interrogé un jour un spécialiste
français des services secrets dont je
tirer le nom j'ai recueilli auprès de
lui la confidence suivante il m'a dit
cette fois je n'oublierai jamais les
services n'oublie jamais même 35 ou 40
ans après la crédibilité le crédit d'un
service c'est de zigouiller les traîtres
et là dessus il ne faut pas oublier que
le colonel du kagué Vladimir Poutine a
été formé donc vous nous
dites que je retire
l'autre mais vous avez pas tout à fait
répondu la Russie en Afrique peut-être
lié à l'activité de Wagner là-bas ou en
Syrie s'il en reste ou sur le front
ukrainien est-ce que la Russie ne peut
pas s'en passer
continuer pas besoin d'avoir pris goji
quelqu'un d'autre peut commander Wagner
je veux dire il y a certainement des
gens derrière il y a beaucoup d'anciens
militaires dans Wagner donc il y a
quelqu'un qui peut être les épaules
parce que comme tout à l'heure notre
séjour d'un expliqué il y a Wagner plus
l'usine à troll plus l'argent alors
l'argent alimente les magazines l'argent
alimente le système Poutine les trolls
travaillent par exemple pour discréditer
Hillary Clinton
ou la France ou la France
donc
zigouiller si j'ose dire éliminer ou
liquidée Wagner ça n'est pas
satisfaisant parce qu'il faut que
l'usine à troll continue à fonctionner
et que l'argent pompé en Afrique au
Moyen-Orient continuent d'alimenter les
caisses un dernier mot je vous donne la
parole juste après concernant
trigogine frigor propose d'entendre une
réaction parce qu'on se demande où est
pris gojin aujourd'hui écoutez
Xenia bolchakova qui journaliste à CAPA
presque pris Albert long 2022 pour le
documentaire Wagner l'armée de l'ombre
de Poutine
corrélisé avec Alexandra Jousset et Xena
bolchacoa était sur France Inter ce
matin
pour l'instant on ne sait pas où il est
on sait qu'il n'est pas au Belarus il y
a plusieurs options il peut être à
Saint-Pétersbourg il peut être aussi un
petit peu en vadrouille entre les
différentes bases certains le disent
entre Bangui et Saint-Pétersbourg il est
sûrement quand même en Russie vous avez
vu après la perquisition dans les dans
le QG de Wagner on a trouvé les
autorités russes ont trouvé une dizaine
de passeports avec une dizaine de
fausses identités mais on sait jamais
on espère pour lui qu'il a gardé
quelques-uns des faux passeport privoji
et bon qu'est-ce que je pense que là il
a je le rappelle a publié diffuser un
message audio aujourd'hui peut-être pour
se protéger d'une éventuelle je sais pas
détection de du lieu où il peut être
qu'est-ce qui peut lui arriver dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines il va devoir lui se protéger
d'abord de toute façon je serai lui je
ferai très attention à ma santé ça c'est
clair mais
étant donné ce qu'a dit Poutine il y a
deux jours où il a traité de traîtres et
la traîtrise chez lui ça ne se pardonne
pas en plus il a été humilié sur le plan
international pas seulement sur le plan
russe il a été il a subi un affront et
les affront ils ne pardonnent pas donc
il va être obligé de faire quelque chose
parce qu'il doit faire un exemple et il
ne peut pas laisser ça comme ça je veux
dire il va falloir qu'il réagissent
d'une manière ou d'une autre et les
hommes de la ministre Wagner ils vont
int de l'armée c'est ce qu'on peut
imaginer dans le mois de juillet c'était
ce qui était prévu donc ça ça va arriver
alors allez-y
donc toujours dans cette déclaration
elle dit que
une vingtaine de minutes dans ce débat
j'aurais quand même qu'on se concentre
maintenant sur Vladimir Poutine un
président russe qui est apparu en
difficulté samedi à la télévision on
vous propose un extrait de ce discours
les actions qui divisent notre unité
sont en fait une trahison de notre
peuple et de nos compagnons d'armes qui
combattent maintenant c'est un coup de
poignard dans le dos de notre pays et de
notre peuple
je voyais qu'on commence par revenir sur
cette journée de samedi qu'est-ce qui se
passe au Kremlin c'est quoi c'est une
sorte de panique quel mot vous employez
pour caractériser ce qui s'est passé au
Kremlin samedi je crois que le Kremlin a
été désemparé surpris
tout ce qui est fait aujourd'hui pour
nous convaincre du contraire y compris
beaucoup de rumeurs autour des des
prototines qui disent que Poutine
n'avait monté tout ça avait organisé un
gigantesque piège pour Prigogine moi j'y
crois pas une seconde de toute évidence
Vladimir Poutine est surpris par
l'ampleur et par l'audace si j'ose dire
de de trigogine c'est évident
deuxièmement il y a un indice très sûr
c'est que je répète des hélicoptères ont
été abattus les pilotes de hélicoptère
membres de l'armée régulière de la
Fédération de Russie sont tués donc il y
a des victimes ça n'est pas bon pour
l'homme qui a construit toute son image
depuis des décennies sur la force la
stabilité l'offense faite à la Russie
qui serait lavée face à cette Occident
décadents qui ne qui ne cherchent qu'à
déstabiliser la Russie tous les
fondamentaux du putinisme se trouve en
une fraction de temps
pulvérisée par la prise de Rostov sur le
don de la base militaire de restauration
ça n'est pas possible de construire un
récit favorable à Poutine autour de
cette affaire alors on reparlera des
conséquences à l'international dans un
instant Hélène blanc mais en interne à
quel point ça peut fragiliser Vladimir
Poutine en interne ce qui s'est passé
vous savez je pense que ça fait un petit
moment déjà
il y a une lutte de pouvoir et que
certains essayent de se positionner pour
éventuellement prendre la suite alors je
sais qu'on avance des noms mais je pense
que pour l'instant c'est un peu
prématuré parce que évidemment Poutine
va s'accrocher au pouvoir jusqu'à son
dernier souffle tel que je connais le
bonhomme il va pas s'en aller il va pas
démissionner et même s'il perdait la
guerre il trouverait le moyen de
raconter une belle fable aux Russes en
disant vous savez c'était pas possible
on avait contre nous le monde entier
l'autre dans l'Occident les Américains
etc on s'est bien battu on n'a pas
rougir l'honneur et sauf mais
malheureusement la guerre est perdue et
il resterait au pouvoir à mon avis tout
le monde s'imagine que s'y perd la
guerre il va s'en aller pas du tout à
mon avis il va faire tout ce qui peut
pour rester même s'il perd la guerre je
suis d'accord
sauf si justement l'entourage décide que
ça suffit alors ça on peut plus l'ex il
a été porté au pouvoir par un des clans
du KGB qui n'est pas homogène et celui
qui a apporté poutine au pouvoir a été
le plus fort à ce moment-là dans les
années 2000
mais il y a d'autres clans qui ont
peut-être aussi l'heure candidat parce
que désormais la Russie est gouvernée
par le KGB tout le monde le sait par
Poutine interposée donc si on veut
continuer dans la même tradition il
faudra prendre quelqu'un du sérail et
dans tout ça autrement et dans tout ça
l'opinion russe cette journée de samedi
est-ce qu'elle peut laisser des traces
chez les par exemple chez les Moscou
vite c'est vrai qu'ils sont ils sont pas
sortis dans la rue en masse samedi enfin
alors qu'il y avait quand même peut-être
une tension palpable c'est c'est comment
vous l'analysez il y a un contrat avec
Vladimir Poutine et la population Russie
la stabilité la tranquillité je fais mon
business c'était plus tout à fait là
tranquille et même plus il était rompu
une fraction de seconde il y a une
déstabilisation qui a duré très peu de
temps d'ailleurs on a bien vu il y a
même des gens qui pouvait faire des
selfies avec les hommes de Wagner et
puis tout est rentré dans l'ordre parce
que il y a un désir de stabilité et
regarder aujourd'hui sur toutes les
télévisions et ce qui était montré
c'était business à jugement on a
retrouvé la stabilité on a retrouvé le
calme et il y a ce ce désir si vous
voulez très profond qui nous qui nous
manque parfois pour expliquer ce qui se
passe cette absence de qu'on pourrait
dire de protestation forte parce qu'on
dit oui mais la Russie c'est c'est du
sérieux quand on proteste je suis désolé
on ira c'est du sérieux aussi quand on
proteste et ça continue donc il y a ce
contrat qui est très important qui est
passé quand même avec la population et
qui finalement bon ben écoutez ils vont
ils vont rentrer dans dans l'ordre en
quelque sorte je croyais ça va pas alors
ça peut créer des doutes mais je crois
que les Russes ne sont tout au fond
d'eux même pas dupe ils sont pas du
pissables je pense ils savent ils ont
conscience mais ils ne bouge pas
des éléments la vue dans le dans le
sujet d'ouverture de Jonathan Dupré
c'est extrait d'une vidéo assez lunaire
elle a une blonde de Vladimir Poutine
alors soit disant dater d'aujourd'hui
évidemment personne n'est capable de
dire quand elle a été enregistrée pas un
mot de ce qui s'est passé samedi pas un
mot sur Wagner ça peut être une vieille
vidéo ressortie du des tiroirs tout à
fait ça peut être une vidéo qui a été
enregistrée avant les événements et qui
parle d'un petit c'est une petite
histoire une petite réunion qui n'a pas
une grosse économique économique du côté
de tout là qui n'a qui est pas un Daveau
sous quelque chose d'important diffusé
pour montrer qu'il est qu'il est
toujours manette que la vie normale
reprend comme si dans la méthode
calmement tout va bien
mais je pense que ça va laisser des
traces plus peut-être à l'international
qu'en Russie alors justement on va en
parler Mathieu qu'est-ce que ça révèle
de la fragilité intérieure russe de la
défenseuse de la sécurité de voir
quelqu'un qui peut comme ça vous l'avez
bien c'est l'une des phrases de prix
gaugine aujourd'hui monter sur nos je
redis dans son message audio pardon
Christian l'avancée de Wagner vers
Moscou a révélé de graves problèmes de
sécurité en Russie et là il est dans la
droite tout à l'heure de ces discours
récurrents depuis des mois ça révèle
fondamentalement le fait que la violence
légale n'est plus le privilège de l'État
russe mais qu'elle est partagée par
d'autres groupes groupuscules encore une
fois d'origine mafieuse comme on le
disait tout à l'heure comme Wagner mais
il y en a aussi d'autres il y a quoi 300
millilitres
les gouverneurs des provinces eux-mêmes
qui sont ces affidés à se doter d'une
milice et certains d'entre eux en ont de
très sérieuses donc c'est une véritable
maladie la gangrène du régime c'est
c'est pourquoi le régime est atteint
dans ces fondamentaux même
c'est à dire alors c'est intéressant
parce que d'un côté on a une Patricia
lemonnière qui nous dit mais de toute
façon l'opinion bouge pas il y a une
sorte de plaque Poutine et là vous vous
dites que le régime est atteint dans ces
que le régime est atteint et ça n'est
pas du tout contradictoire
vous avez raison et je vais rappeler un
fait très simple lorsque le mur de
Berlin est tombé l'opinion publique
russe je me souviens parce que j'étais
là-bas en Russie il y avait une
indifférence absolue du peuple russe qui
ne pensait que euh
elle a au fait de fin d'année on était
au mois de novembre
etc c'est passé par-dessus la tête de la
population mais le fait majeur cette
fois qui n'est pas dans le qui va dans
le sens de ce que dit Hélène blanche
c'est-à-dire Poutine et n'est pas encore
dévissé et il n'est pas déboulonné comme
les statues de Lénine l'entêté il n'est
pas encore des boulonné parce que
l'élite russe n'a pas pris fête et cause
pour Prigogine et ça c'est très frappant
ils n'ont pas lâché Poutine le peuple
était indifférent l'élite est restée
pour Poutine et ça a permis de
circonscrire cette événement stupéfiant
internationale on y vient tout de suite
et on commence avec vous Mathieu sur la
réaction française comment l'Élysée
comment Emmanuel Macron réagit à
l'offensive de Wagner prudemment dans
l'entretien qui l'accordé au journal de
la Provence ce matin le président de la
République nous livre une analyse des
plus sobre qu'il a d'ailleurs répété
tout au long de la journée alors il dit
cela montre les divisions qui existent
au sein du camp russe la fragilité à la
fois de ces armées et de ses forces
auxiliaires comme le groupe Wagner vous
allez me dire nous voilà bien avancé il
y a pas besoin d'un grand géopolitologue
pour sortir une phrase pareille mais
cette économie de mots et de
commentaires elle traduit bien en fait
l'effet de sidération et l'assaut de
précaution qu'après aucun provoqué
l'offensive de Vigny Prigogine en
Occident samedi d'ailleurs les champs
séries occidentales c'était
spectaculaire ont pris un soin
particulier à ne rien dire de définitif
ni d'engageant et surtout employer
toutes les mêmes termes alors ça
commence toujours pareil que ce soit
Paris à Washington à Berlin à Londres à
Rome ou pour l'Union européenne on dit
toujours on suit l'évolution de la
situation de très près alors c'est on
suit on surveille l'évolution très près
ensuite on reste en contact permanent
avec ces partenaires ou ses alliés et
puis enfin on finit toujours par
rappeler que on se tient au côté surtout
de l'Ukraine voilà alors pourquoi cette
précaution d'abord parce que personne ne
savait comment la faire les tourner et
sur ce point quand même difficile de
leur donner tort ensuite parce que
personne ne voulait le sentiment ne
voulait donner pardon le sentiment de
s'ingérer dans une affaire Russo russe
comme l'a dit le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui à
Marseille personne voulait donner le
sentiment qu'une puissance occidentale
pouvait avoir été à la manœuvre d'une
quelconque façon que que ce soit le
Washington Post c'est le New York Times
ont révélé ce week-end que la CIA savait
que la révolte de Wagner était imminente
mais pas question surtout pas question
d'offrir la lumière Poutine un argument
en faveur de sa propagande contre
l'accident et puis enfin dernier raison
on en a parlé longuement qui veut gagner
le prix gaugine n'a jamais fait figure
de sauveur bien au contraire et si
chacun se félicite secrètement que de
voir le camp russe diviser et donc
affaibli mais personne dans le camp
occidental ne pouvait se réjouir de voir
gagner Prigogine réussir son offensive
et surtout pas la France qui fait les
frais en Afrique particulièrement des
exasations du groupe Wagner qui lui
aimerait bien voir circonscrire
l'influence de Paris donc en gros entre
la peste Poutine et le choléra a pris
gojin mais il était plus sage de se
tenir à distance
Hélène blanc samedi je dis ça il y a que
la Turquie je crois qui qui réagit assez
vite pour soutenir Poutine alors
aujourd'hui c'est plus la même chose il
y a c'est c'est ces alliés on va dire
traditionnels qui qui sont montés au
créneau mais on a entendu la Chine
d'ailleurs ça c'est intéressant parce
que c'est effectivement vers la Chine il
faut peut-être se tourner est-ce que on
a parlé de la fragilisation de Poutine
en interne c'est complexe on l'a compris
et en externe qu'est-ce que vous en
dites est-ce que ces alliés qui
cherchent en lui effectivement l'homme
fort la stabilité dont on parlait
peuvent
réfléchir se détourner comment comme on
l'analyse mais il est possible que
certains
effarés parce qu'il s'est passé parce
que c'est vrai que c'est assez
surréaliste
commence à prendre leur distance et à
réfléchir en se disant finalement
Poutine n'aime pas le fond que nous
croyons et d'ailleurs c'est vrai qu'il
n'est pas aussi costaud qu'il était au
début de son de ses premiers mandats
mais je voudrais dire deux choses la
première c'est que la
la propagande
qui est menée en Europe
atteint les dirigeants et beaucoup
disent oui mais ça peut être pire on a
Poutine d'accord mais ça le prochain
peut être pire c'est exactement ce
qu'ils veulent qu'on pense que les
Russes veulent qu'on pense et
malheureusement ça marche
la porte-parole du ministère chinois des
Affaires étrangères a quand même réagi à
réagi aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui que
effectivement qu'il fallait préserver
l'équilibre la stabilité du pays parce
que n'oubliez pas samedi il y avait le
vice-ministre des Affaires étrangères
russes en Chine donc ils se sont vus et
je ne sais pas s'il était convoqué ça je
ne sais pas si le rendez-vous était
prévu mais en tout cas il a dû avoir une
explication au carré parce que la Chine
ça n'intéresse pas du tout de voir une
milice montée comme ça à 400 km de la
capitale alors ça se passerait pas à
Pékin je vous rassure parce que là ces
zimping a déjà purgé l'armée il a mis
tout le monde bien dans le bon sens il a
il s'est servi de la lutte contre la
corruption pour replacer son son petit
monde et donc il tient l'armée ça ne
pourrait donc pas se passer chez lui
mais quand il voit son allié ou son
vassal ça dépend comme on veut analyser
la situation se déliter ne serait-ce que
quelques heures c'est sûr que ça ne fait
pas plaisir je vous donne la parole tout
de suite Christian mais pour alimenter
cette partie du débat sur les réactions
internationales il y a quand même cette
réaction du secrétaire américain Anthony
blinkel c'est intéressant parce qu'il
remonte le fil de l'histoire jusqu'au
début de l'invia de l'invasion russe
février 2022 écoutons-le
il y a 16 mois les Russes étaient aux
portes de Kiev en Ukraine pensant
prendre la ville en quelques jours et
effacer l'Ukraine de la carte en tant
que pays indépendant ce weekend les
forces russes ont dû défendre Moscou la
capitale de la Russie contre les
mercenaires créés par Poutine lui-même
trigogi lui-même dans cet incident à
soulever de profondes questions sur les
prémices même de l'agression de la
Russie contre l'Ukraine en disant que le
pays où l'OTAN ne représentait pas une
menace pour la Russie ce qui fait partie
du discours de Poutine cela a défié
directement son autorité donc cela
soulève devrait question et révèle des
fissures réelles
est-ce que le secrétaire d'État
américain s'adresse aussi à la Chine
évidemment
sûrement il envoie le message très
clairement regardez ce qui se passe
quand on se comporte de cette manière là
mais il faut se méfier trigogine de
toutes les façons parce que il a dit
tellement de choses et leur contraire
oubliez jamais que c'est un homme on a
la mémoire courte parce que c'est un
moule à Apple ce prix gaugine mais il a
quand même proposé de donner des
coordonnées de base et de points
stratégiques russes aux
Ukrainiens en échange d'une tractation
il a fait ça
[Musique]
donc et il est exact au départ il a
promis d'apporter à Poutine la victoire
à barmouth sur un plateau d'argent et
qu'ensuite il a dit effectivement que la
Russie c'était engagée dans une mauvaise
guerre qu'elle ne gagnerait pas il a
tout dit étouffé mais ce que je trouve
plus intéressant c'est quand même les
républiques périphériques aussi regardez
du côté du au mois de janvier de l'année
dernière un mois et un mois à peine
avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie la Russie sauve la mise du
dictateur local enfin c'est pas tout à
fait indicateur mais du régime
autoritaire monsieur tokayev il lui
sauve la mise les Russes envoie des
trous parce que il y a une meuf il y a
des émeutes et tout est réprimé est au
caif garde son siège aujourd'hui te
caieve qui a plusieurs reprises à
marquer ses distances avec Poutine le
désapprouve et signal avec une verdeur
verbale clair et net que le système
politique russe et menacé donc et ça
c'est c'est pas rien le Kazakhstan c'est
quand même un pays assez important dans
le système post soviétique il y a
d'autres réactions de ce type là et
finalement le seul ça participe de la
fragilisation qui a été solidaire sans
discussion avec
lui aussi en son temps donc au mois de
juillet 2016 sauver la misère d'organ
qu'en Erdogan a été a dû affronter un
coup d'État militaire Poutine donné des
conseils qui étaient judicieux
d'ailleurs qui ont permis de se rétablir
et de cerner les poutchistes donc c'est
quand même
la grande solitude de Vladimir Poutine
cette affaire justement Patricia
lemonnière je ne sais pas si c'est
possible mais Vladimir Poutine peut-il
devenir encore plus paranoïa qu'il ne
l'était déjà après cette épisode
envoie effectivement en guerre plus
c'est-à-dire soit ça craquel de
l'intérieur et finalement dans un
certain nombre de temps difficiles à
définir et bien il y aura un changement
voilà venu de l'intérieur soit au
contraire essayer je pencherai plutôt
là-dessus vous savez quand on se casse
l'os de la jambe quand il se ressoudent
et là il est ressoudé il est encore plus
solide dit-on
oui
on va c'est une c'est une option c'est
une option qui ne se durcisse
[Musique]
qu'il fasse une répression très forte
n'oubliez pas qu'il a le FSO autour de
lui qui est un corps d'élite qui assure
la garde prétorienne du Kremlin 5000
hommes la garde pretorienne autour de
lui c'est 5000 abonnés lui a fait sauter
20000 hommes il y a le KGB il a il a le
Gru il a quand même des forces qui lui
donnent quand même les moyens de mener
un c'est très pression
d'éliminer ce qu'il le gène et il a
aussi alors il a les oligarques qui sont
effectivement qui font moins de business
mais dans la grande redistribution qui
va s'opérer peut-être des deniers de
Wagner il peut en remercier certains à
suivre merci beaucoup à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat et
ne rappelle le titre de votre livre
goodbye Poutine on n'est pas tout à fait
mais qui sait du KGB au crime de guerre
publié aux éditions
Ginko à bientôt sur public